people run for office and they run for
you know president or whatever it is and
they run on different issues right build
a wall I'm with her Obamacare affordable
health you know health insurance like
you know uh cost of insurance you know
immigration taxes rich people top one
percent billionaires all these things
they run on
you think if somebody ran and they laid
out their top 10 plan and you know one
of the things in the top five is to
investigate what's really going on with
these issues you think that would be
something that would be uh resonate with
millions of Americans that they would
want to get to the bottom of this yeah I
think so because even today despite all
the mainstream media like missing
disinformation about stuff like Epstein
people are like I'd really like to see
that Client List you know